hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to continue our series
on in-game tactics now we'll let you
know that the last video did not quite
get the number of
views that i was hoping for so not sure
if that means
uh that everyone's just not as
interested in the end games but i am
going to try something
different and that is to make shorter
videos of
in games still have a lot of videos that
i'd like to make on endgames but let me
know if you
like the shorter condensed versions
of these i want to make sure that you
understand that the concepts but think i
can get through them
very quickly so without further ado
we'll go ahead and jump into it
one thing that i see a lot in chess
games
people send me their games all the time
to review
is when they approach the in-game
they're many times not sure
the best way to approach a king and pond
in game now sometimes they have a king
and a pawn versus to king
i've done another video on that i will
do others as well
but sometimes it's it's just like this
it's both sides have equal material
and they don't know how to approach in
this position right here
one thing that white many times will try
and it's white's move
is to race as fast as possible over to
this pawn on a7 capture it
thinking that okay the king and the pawn
are going to be here white's going to be
up in material
but unfortunately that's not going to
work and so let's take a look at
why that does not work and then talk
about some of the reasons
that it doesn't and then figure out the
best line that white can take to make
sure that they
win in this position
so white has three options can come to
e8
e7 or e6 e7 and e8 are going to work
very similar so we'll take a look at
that
e7 and you could see black coming here
to
c3 king 2 d6 doesn't really matter d6 or
d7
white is still just approaching this a7
square
and then king here to d4
now this is a an important square and
we'll take a look at this later in
the video but d4 and d5
are critical squares as well as c7 this
will make more sense as we get later
into the video now from white standpoint
they can't really go south so they're
gonna be
they can't go to c5 d5 or
e5 so they're just going to continue
with their same plan as before and
that's to come over to
this pawn here on a7 so they're going to
march that way king's going to come to
e5
king 2 b7 king to d6
and after king to a7 then king c7 as we
said before this is a critical square
if black can get his king to c7 this is
going to be
a drawn game now the king can't come to
b8
the king is pretty much stuck so let's
say it comes to
a8 well then now just king to c8 still
able to get to c7 fairly easily and then
after a7 then king to
c7 and this is stalemates
white cannot move at all no one's under
check so this is a drawn game so it
looked like
white could just race over take that
black pawn
but that did not work out so let's go
back to the very beginning and start to
take a look at
where white went wrong and how white
could have continued
to actually win the game
now earlier i mentioned that these
squares in the center
this d4 and d5 are critical squares and
eventually white wants to stop
the black king from coming here to c7
so you always want to calculate where
your opponent can go
and then stop them from getting there
before you do anything else make sure
that you stop them from executing the
game plan that they have
white knows that they're going to be
able to reach the pawns
faster than the black king right here
because it's white's
move but they need to make sure they go
about it the right way and since the
squares in the center here are critical
then white needs to start with the move
king 2
e6 now black's going to same plane as
before needs to come to the center
king 2 c3 but then after
king 2 d5 you can see that black cannot
move
to the d4 square this exactly where
black wanted to go can't come to
c4 as well so if we look at the next
move for
black probably just going to come to b4
makes sense you don't want to get
further away from the action here king
to
c6 and maybe king to c4 because it's
again blocking off some of the squares
that the black king
can go to so if we continue king to
b7 king up here to c5
but after the king captures on a7 you
can see that
in the earlier example the king was able
to come here to
c7 secure this square it's not able to
do that it tries
it's coming here to c6 but now i can
play the move king
to b8 and now
the black king cannot come to c7
and that is the main difference in white
stopping the king
from coming to this d4 square early on
and so now doesn't really matter where
the black king goes let's say it comes
here to b6
well now you can see pawn to a7
and then the next move it's going to
push forward to a8 and it's going to
promote to a queen so very very
important
that white starts with the move e6 and
if it doesn't
let's say you're playing as black
you need to understand that if they make
a mistake and play king to e7
that you shouldn't try to race them you
shouldn't play king 2
b3 because they could just play king 2
d7 and even if you try to go to the
center of the board if you play
king 2 c4 now well you're just behind
in a move they can play king 2 c6
and this is stopping a lot of the
squares that you'd want to go to whether
that's c5 or
d5 and so they're really just forcing
you to play king 2 d4 but you've reached
the square
one move slower than you would have
before so now they can play
king 2 b7 and now you're chasing them
king 2
c5 king 2 a7
but then you can see king 2 c6 are now
king to b8 and they're stopping that
square here on
c7 so because you made that one critical
error of king to b3 early on
you're not able to reach the squares
that you needed to so this is
an in-game tactic always be thinking
about how your opponent can stop you
from winning even if you calculate yes i
can get to the pond quicker
see how you can make sure to stop your
opponent from
stopping you so i have a lot more of
these videos but if you wouldn't mind
feel free hitting the like button
let me know if there's other types of
videos you'd like me to see in the end
game do have some king and pawn
in games whether that's just more king
or pawns on one side
i do think king and pawn is something
that everyone
should focus more on but definitely
interested to hear what everyone
has to say thank you so much for
watching i'll see you guys in the next
video
you